meagan Marco receives her royal coat of
arms and it's a big break in tradition
it's a the Dilma looks like the duchess
of sussex is adjusting to her new life
as a royal including adapting to the
british family's protocols on Friday
Kensington Palace revealed Marcos new
coat of arms and et is breaking down
what it all means the design is split in
half with Prince Harry's coat on the
left side and the right side there are
nods to the Duchess's home state the
blue background represents the Pacific
Ocean off the California coast
then there's golden rays across the
shield symbolic of the sunshine of
California and just beneath the shield
on the grass a bed of golden poppies
California's state flower the palace
shared that the white bird with a tiara
symbolized Meghan opposite Harry's lion
quote the Duchess of Sussex is a
songbird with wings elevated as if
flying and an open beak which with the
quills represents the power of
communication whatever we have to tackle
together or individually will always be
us together as a team unlike Kate
Middleton's coat of arms which reflected
her mother's maiden name there are no
signs of Marcos family included in the
design and another break-in tradition
the coat of arms is usually presented to
the father of the bride before a royal
wedding but Megan's dad Thomas Marco of
course missed the big day
you